[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedriger in allen einen schönen guten
Abend das Wichtigste vom Sport später
wieder mit dir Norbert sehr gerne
schönen guten Abend auch von mir dann
blicken wir jetzt gemeinsam auf unseren
themenüberblick
nach der Überschwemmungskatastrophe in
Libyen gehen die Behörden von immer mehr
Toten aus internationale Hilfe auch aus
Deutschland ist auf dem Weg
bei ruhiger See kommen tausende
Flüchtlinge auf Lampedusa an die
italienische Insel hat den Notstand
erklärt
der Bundesgesundheitsminister warnt auch
in diesem Winter könnte es bei
kindermedikamenten Engpässe geben
[Musik]
die Situation im Katastrophengebiet von
Libyen ist immer noch unübersichtlich
offiziell wird noch von ca 5.000 Toten
gesprochen aber der Bürgermeister der am
stärksten betroffenen Hafenstadt birna
hält bis zu 20.000 tote für möglich
welche Wucht und Zerstörung die
Wassermassen entfalteten das sehen wir
auf Satellitenaufnahmen ein Stadtteil
mit Häusern und Fußballfeld vor der Flut
und hier danach und so sah der Hafen von
drinne ursprünglich aus und so nach den
verheerenden Überschwemmungen
mittlerweile läuft internationale Hilfe
an aus dem Namen Osten etwa und auch
Europa hilft inzwischen golini beginnt
ihren Bericht im Schwert zerstörten
zusammen
was von der Küstenstadt Susa übrig blieb
Verwüstung und Schlamm überall
einwohnererzählen dass es kein
Trinkwasser gibt dass der Geruch von
Verwesung in der Luft liegt dass viele
Leichen kaum identifizierbar sind die
Aufräumarbeiten hier haben es später
angefangen
und wir brauchen Strom seit Samstag
haben wir hier keinen Strom die
Kanalisation muss entstand gesetzt
werden wir sind wirklich bei 0 hier
das Meer vor der Küste der am
schlimmsten betroffenen Stadt ist braun
geworden
das ägyptische Militär ist vor Ort und
hilft
Rettungskräfte suchen das Meer nach
Leichen ab
ein Großvater umarmt seinen Sohn er
trauert um seinen Engel
der Bürgermeister der Stadt befürchtet
18 bis 20.000 Tote
ich habe sieben acht Angehörige verloren
aber es gibt ganze Familien die umkamen
ganze Gebäude stürzten ein und fielen
auf Sie
augenzeugen berichten die Hilfsmaßnahmen
seien chaotisch und unkoordiniert viele
Familien hätten auch vergangene Nacht
kein Wasser keine Nahrungsmittel gehabt
das Militär hat die Stadt abgesperrt und
Checkpoints eingerichtet unabhängige
Medien heißt es sollen dort nur noch
unter Aufsicht eines aufpasses der
Regierung arbeiten dürfen
nach dem Libyen die EU um Hilfe gebeten
hatte hat auch Deutschland Hilfsgüter
zugesagt dass Technische Hilfswerk
schickte Generatoren Zelte und Betten
zwei Maschinen der Luftwaffe flogen sie
heute ins Überschwemmungsgebiet
und so könnten sie die Menschen in
Libyen helfen über das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die iban.de
65-100
400-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Libyen infos auch unter spenden.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Text Seite 89.0
groß auch die Not in Teilen Marokkos
nach dem verheerenden Erdbeben warten
weiter Hunderttausende auf Unterstützung
Hilfe aus Deutschland wird das Land aber
vorerst nicht bekommen ein für heute
geplanter Flug des Roten Kreuzes wurde
kurzfristig abgesagt wegen Auflagen der
marokkanischen Regierung im
Erdbebengebiet sind tausende Häuser
zerstört viele Familien verbringen die
kalten Nächte im Freien
unicef-schätzt das allein etwa 100.000
Kinder von der Katastrophe betroffen
sind laut marokkanischen Behörden sind
rund 3000 Menschen bei dem Beben
gestorben
wir gehen nach Marrakesch zu unserer
Kollegin Anne Arendt eine die
internationale Hilfe läuft nur
schleppend an wo genau liegt das Problem
eine offiziell wird da auf Regularien
verwiesen dass darauf dass die Regierung
je nach Bedarf entscheide oder auch mal
das zu viel Hilfe auf einmal
kontraproduktiv sein könnte das macht
erstmal sprachlos wenn man gesehen hat
wie sehr die Menschen in den zerstörten
Bergdörfern auf Nahrung warten auf
Medizin und angesichts der kalten Nächte
auf Zelten dahinter steckt aber wohl
auch ein politisches Motiv wenn man
schaut aus welchen Ländern die
Unterstützung akzeptiert wurde das sind
alles befreundete Staaten die sich
zuletzt in geopolitischen Fragen also
etwa in westerhara Konflikt auf die
Seite Marokkos geschlagen haben keiner
kritisiert hier den König öffentlich aus
Angst vor Repressalien und auch der
Schock über die Erdbeben nach der ist
noch sehr präsent aber je mehr Zeit
vergeht und je mehr die Hilfe auf sich
warten lässt desto mehr
Opfer wird dieses Erdbeben natürlich
auch fordern und desto größer wird die
Verzweiflung und es besteht auch die
Gefahr dass internationale Spenden also
finanzielle Spenden dass die aus dem
Ausland dass diese Unterstützung
nachlässt vielen Dank nach Marrakesch
jetzt kommen wir zur heimischen
Wirtschaft bei uns schwächelt die
Konjunktur ja schon seit Monaten
weswegen die Forderungen nach einer
Zinspause zuletzt lauter wurden aber die
Europäische Zentralbank hob den Leitzins
wieder an um weitere
0,25% Punkte auf jetzt 4,5 %. bis Juli
2022 verfolgte die EZB über mehrere
Jahre eine Nullzinspolitik seitdem
wurden die Zinsen 10 Mal in Folge erhöht
und so versucht die Notenbank die hohe
Inflation in den Griff zu bekommen mehr
fahren wir jetzt von Stefan Schlösser
sie könnten noch viel mehr Photovoltaik
installieren doch die hohen Zinsen
bremsen sie aus mit seiner Firma
entwickelt theodoro Krapp auch große
Anlagen und Solarparks manche Projekte
können aber nicht umgesetzt werden die
die Nachfrage ist da und wir könnten
schneller wachsen als was wir jetzt tun
weil die Finanzierungskosten sind
momentan uns zu hoch für Großprojekte
müssen die müssen wir ja verschieben
weil das sind sechs dringend Bereich ist
für kleinere Projekte müssen wir im
Lager eben das Material halten im
Rekordtempo hat die EZB die Zinsen
hochgeschraubt um die Inflation in den
Griff zu bekommen heute liegt sie erneut
nach der Leitzins steigt auf 4,5 %
Punkte
die Inflation geht weiter zurück wird
aber voraussichtlich noch zu lange zu
hoch bleiben wir sind entschlossen dafür
zu sorgen dass die Inflation zeitnah zu
unserem mittelfristigen Ziel von 2%
zurückkehrt
hohe Zinsen hohe Inflation gerade für
Deutschland eine gefährliche Mischung
die Inflationsrate ist hierzulande mit
6,4% deutlich höher als in den anderen
großen Volkswirtschaften der Eurozone
gleichzeitig schrumpft die deutsche
Wirtschaft während sie in den anderen
Ländern noch zulegen kann
wenn die EZB das klare Ziel der
Inflationsbekämpfung hat da war diese
Zinserhöhung die für mich die letzte war
absolut richtig aber jetzt wird die
Phase vom und das wird ja immer stärker
dann betonen dass einer
fahrseeszins-pause dann im nächsten Jahr
die erste Zinssenkung kommt damit die
Wirtschaft wieder Luft bekommt die
meisten Beobachter gehen ohnehin davon
aus dass die Inflation weiter sinken
wird
zum Krieg in der Ukraine Russland soll
mehrere Regionen erneut mit Drohnen
angegriffen haben so Kiew ein Großteil
konnte abgewehrt werden gemeldet wurden
auch schwere Explosionen auf der von
Russland annektierten Krim nah der
Großstadt die toria anwohner hatten die
Detonationen gefilmt dort soll ein
russisches Flugabwehrsystem getroffen
worden sein
die italienische Mittelmeerinsel
Lampedusa ist der Anlaufpunkt für
Migranten aus Afrika mehr als 8000
Bootsflüchtlinge sind dort seit Beginn
der Woche an Land gegangen das erste
Aufnahme Lager ist hoffnungslos
überfüllt Lampedusa liegt zwischen
Sizilien und Tunesien die meisten
Menschen machen sich in Fax auf den
gefährlichen Weg nach Europa Luftlinie
sind das rund 190 km Annette
chaotische Zustände im Hafen von
Lampedusa Migranten versuchen die
Absperrungen zu durchbrechen Einheiten
der Polizei drängen sie zurück in der
letzten Tagen waren immer neue Boote
angekommen alleine am Dienstag 120 deren
Insassen waren in Tunesien an Bord
gegangen die Lage auf der Insel ist
angespannt Bewohner die bisher der
Migrationssituation mit Geduld
begegneten versammelten sich gestern zum
Protest
wir wollen den Frieden leben und wir
wollen dass die Verfassung auch auf
Lampedusa gilt das aufnahmelade der
Insel eigentlich für etwa 400 Personen
ausgelegt ist komplett überfüllt
zeitweise mit bis zu 6.800 Menschen bei
der Verteilung von Wasser und Essen
kommt es zu Unruhen
die rechte Regierung Italiens war
angetreten mit dem Versprechen die
Migration zu verringern viel zum
Ministerpräsident Salvini klagt nun die
EU an angesichts der großen Zunahme von
Ankünften
sie sind ein Symbol für ein Europa das
nicht da ist das distanziert ist das
abgelenkt ist das mit schuldig ist und
dass die einzelnen Länder mit ihren
Problemen alleine lässt
auf Lampedusa bringen die Behörden
derweil seit gestern verstärkt Migranten
per Fähre oder Flugzeug aufs Festland um
die Situation zu entspannen das Problem
wird dadurch nicht gelöst
in Thüringen sorgt eine Steuersenkung
für Wirbel im Landtag hat sich die
Opposition am Nachmittag gegen die
rot-rot-grüne Minderheitsregierung
durchgesetzt konkret geht es um einen
Gesetzentwurf der CDU für eine
niedrigere Grunderwerbsteuer der bekam
nur eine Mehrheit weil neben der FDP die
AFD die entscheidenden Stimmen bei
steuerte Vertreter der Landesregierung
kritisieren die Abstimmung als einen
Pakt mit dem Teufel die Thüringer CDU
weiß die Vorwürfe zurück ihr GS um die
Entlastung für Familien und den
Mittelstand
Melanie Haag vor dem Thüringer Landtag
für uns wie ist die Entscheidung
einzuschätzen und welche Folgen könnte
sie haben
ja also zum einen sind die Folgen das
für den Haushalt dann künftig geschätzt
rund 50 Millionen Euro weniger zur
Verfügung stehen werden und das andere
ist dass die AFD hier zum ersten Mal in
einer
haushaltsrelevanten Frage mit
entschieden hat man muss sagen es ist
aber nicht zum ersten Mal dass die AFD
hier in Thüringen zum
Mehrheitsbeschaffer wurde wurde sie
unter anderem auch schon für
Rot-Rot-Grün Mario Vogt cdu-fraktionchef
der heute diesen Antrag hier einbrachte
betonte noch mal es gab keine Absprachen
mit der AFD vorab es werde auch keine
Kooperation geben und in seiner Rede
zitierte er auch Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz der sagte man dürfe seine
Entscheidung nicht vom
Abstimmungsverhalten der AFD abhängig
machen das Ganze war heute hier wieder
eine hitzige Debatte und man darf nicht
vergessen der Antrag wurde bereits im
März im Landtag eingebracht und bis
heute konnten alle miteinander keiner
Einigung Herr bei führen und das zeigt
auch wie schwierig die Fronten sind und
dass die politischen Reden hier heute
eigentlich noch mal tiefer wurden und
ein Jahr vor den Landtagswahlen in
Thüringen heißt das es dürften hitzige
Debatten und immer wieder die Frage der
Brandmauer zahlt AFD sein die übrigens
hier bei diesem ganzen Gezänk einfach
nur zuschauen brauchte danke für die
Einordnung nachher fort Melanie Haag
bis zur Europawahl da sind es noch neun
Monate aber schon jetzt stellen sich die
Parteien dafür auf womit die Grünen
genau punkten wollen darüber hat die
Partei heute in Berlin beraten über
Ergebnisse und die wichtigsten
Programmpunkte informiert uns jetzt
Patricia Wiedemeyer
es sind viele gute Vorsätze viele
Versprechen für ein schöneres
gerechteres Europa das die Grünen da
heute präsentierten es gehe jetzt darum
den Frieden und auch den Wohlstand zu
erhalten das ist die aktuelle Aufgabe
dieses Europas und zum Wohlstand zu
sichern und vor allem dort mitzuspielen
wo der Wohlstand der Zukunft entsteht
und dafür zu sorgen dass er bei den
Menschen ankommt die eine arbeiten um
das zu erreichen gehört für die Grünen
die klimaneutrale Modernisierung der
Wirtschaft eine gemeinsame Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik und eine
Infrastruktur Union dazu
damit muss die Europäische Union ein
Gegenangebot machen zu den
Einflusssphären Denken von
autokratischen Staaten wie China und
Russland auch ein europaweites
Ticketsystem für die Bahn und den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien wollen sie
durchsetzen neu ist dass die Grünen in
ihrem europawahlprogramm eine
CO2-Speicherung unter der Erde nicht
mehr ausschließen und diese prüfen
lassen wollen bisher haben sie das
kategorisch ausgeschlossen doch der
Klimawandel sei inzwischen so weit
fortgeschritten dass eine bloße
Reduzierung des CO2 Ausstoßes nicht mehr
ausreiche jetzt müsste man auch über
neue Technologien diskutieren umstritten
bleibt das Thema Migration innerhalb von
Europa und innerhalb der Grünen
der Generalbundesanwalt hat die
Ermittlungen zu den Anschlägen auf die
Bahn aufgenommen die Behörde hat ein
Verfahren wegen des Verdachts der
Mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen
Vereinigung eröffnet vor einer Woche
hatten Unbekannte Kabelschächte in
Hamburg in Brand gesetzt viele Züge
vielen daraufhin aus die Polizei geht
von einem politischen Motiv aus
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat mit
Ärzten und Apothekern diskutiert wie man
am besten auf Medikamenten Engpässe
reagiert sie erinnern sich vielleicht
waren sogar vielleicht selbst betroffen
verzweifelte Eltern den Apotheken
händeringend auf der Suche nach Fieber
oder Hustensäften so war es wegen
massiver Lieferprobleme im letzten
Winter ganz so schlimm ist es nicht mehr
aber es fehlen noch immer spezielle
Medikamente die Dual
Marion Hill ist genervt Hustensaft
fiebersenker sogar antibiotische Säfte
für Kinder einige Medikamente haben sie
zum Teil seit Monaten nicht mehr gesehen
trotzdem sie bei Herstellern und
direktvermarkt anständig dränge wir sind
ja nicht blöd das heißt wir versuchen
nach Kräften Arzneimittel zu bekommen zu
beschaffen aber wir bekommen nichts weil
nichts auf dem Markt verfügbar ist
manche Kinderärzte haben Eltern sogar im
Frühjahr schon geraten sich im Urlaub im
Ausland mit Medikamenten für ihre Kinder
einzudecken das behebt den Mangel hier
nicht weiß Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach deshalb Krisengipfel am
Morgen im Ministerium die Hilferufe von
Apothekern und Ärzten sind angekommen
die Pharmaunternehmen produzieren nun
rund um die Uhr dadurch dass wir die
Menge erhöht haben sind wir der Meinung
wenn es ein normales Infektionsgeschehen
kommen wird dann werden wir auch für die
Versorgung sicher genügend Ware haben
alle reden von Versorgungssicherheit und
Mengen keiner zunächst vom Preis was
mehr Produktion das Gesundheitssystem
kostet und den Pharmafirmen bringt
bisher haben die den deutschen Markt
eher stiefmütterlich bedient wegen
gedeckelte Abnahmepreise lohnt sich ein
Verkauf im Ausland deutlich mehr auch
wenn nun mehr in Deutschlands Apotheken
landen soll appelliert der Minister
nicht zu horten das Gebot der Stunde der
Vernunft ist bitte keine Hamsterkäufe
etwas leichter wird für Apothekerin Hill
wenn wieder einmal kein Saft da ist dann
darf sie auch Tabletten rausgeben auch
andere Packungsgrößen ohne ein neues
Rezept nun hofft sie dass sie in diesem
Herbst nicht wiederkunden vertrösten
muss
falls Sie heute versucht haben auf
Livestreams in der ZDF Mediathek der
heute App oder auf unsere
Online-Angebote zuzugreifen und das
nicht ging es liegt nicht an ihrer
Technik zu Hause es gibt eine technische
Störung unserer Internetanbindung die
Ursache dafür die ist noch unklar
der erste warntag vor drei Jahren der
startete noch mit einer halben Stunde
Verspätung heute ging der Probealarm
pünktlich um 11 Uhr los
ja bundesweit Schritten heute und
bromten Sirenen und Handys ausgelöst
wurde der Alarm vom Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
in einer ersten Bilanz heißt es dass
System habe den Stresstest bestanden
Norbert jetzt kommen wir zum Fußball
heute mal nicht Nationalmannschaft
sondern Bundesliga ja da gibt es nämlich
morgen zwei Topspiele sowohl bei den
Männern als auch bei den Frauen mit dem
Meister und den Meisterinnen aus München
zunächst Bayern gegen Bayer beide Teams
in Bestform mit drei Siegen in den
ersten drei Spielen
Xavier und so kommt nach München wo er
früher mal gespielt hat als
Tabellenführer Trainer so entscheidend
ist das noch nicht aber beruhigend alle
Spiele sind zurück und ja wie wir werden
das sehen aber ich habe eine gute Gefühl
für morgen bei den Bayern kommt Josua
Kimmich angeschlagen von der
Nationalmannschaft zurück ein Nachteil
der Länderspielpause alles in den
verschiedenen Teams alles in
verschiedenen Prinzipien jetzt kurz
gewesen für zwei Wochen und dann so am
Anfang des Saison ist das nie besonders
schön aber gut startet die Saison jetzt
noch meine
Stadt in München gegen Leverkusen
Freitagabend
bei den Frauen beginnt morgen erst die
neue Saison und da ist das Topspiel
Freiburg gegen Bayern die Meisterin
haben sich für die neue Spielzeit
Personal enorm versteckt
es ist Bewegung drin bei den Bayern und
jede muss ihren Platz finden zehn neue
Spielerinnen sind gekommen im Sommer für
die großen Ziele der neuen Spielzeit ist
jede Position nun doppelt besetzt der
große Kuh die Verpflichtung von
Magdalena Eriksson und pennele harder
ein Traumpaar beide kommen vom FC
Chelsea und beide sollen
schlüsselspielerinnen sein Ericsson in
der Defensive harder will wie bei der WM
mit Dänemark für Tore sorgen auch
deutsche Nationalspielerinnen sind
Leistungsträger im Team Lea Schuler z.B
wenn die Münchnerinnen antreten dann um
Titel zu gewinnen
Freiburg gegen Bayern morgen an live bei
uns im ZDF zu sehen ab 18 Uhr zur
Tischtennis EM in Schweden Achtelfinale
der Männer ja und da hat Deutschland mit
Timo Boll die Ukraine mit 3:0 gezwungen
dabei zeigte auch der achtmalige
einzeleuropameister eine souveräne
Leistung morgen spielt das Team gegen
Kroatien um den Einzug ins Halbfinale
starker Ballwechsel muss man sagen das
deutsche Frauen Team spielt uns
ebenfalls gerade gegen die Ukraine im
Achtelfinale dann vielen Dank Norbert
schöne Spätsommertage die stehen weiter
an aber wann es mit den vorbei ist das
erfahren wir gleich von Katja horneffer
um 21:45 Uhr sehen Sie das heute journal
mit Christian Sievers morgen gibt's uns
wegen Fußballübertragung ausnahmsweise
sind Tick früher gegen 18:45 Uhr schönen
Dank und noch einen schönen Abend für
Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend dass wir schon september
haben merken wir zum Beispiel daran dass
sich die Nebelfelder auch mal länger
halten können am Vormittag sonst aber
stehen die Zeichen noch auf Spätsommer
so meldete Lana K auf Zypern heute 33
Grad Rom 27 und Malaga 30 bei uns in
Deutschland lagen heute die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 18 und 25
Grad jetzt über das Wochenende am Montag
auch noch im Osten kratzen wir
allerdings noch mal an den 30 Grad kaum
vorzustellen bei Tiefsttemperaturen von
nur vier Grad heute Nacht in der
Lüneburger Heide Bilder bleibt die Nacht
ganz im Norden und auch im Südwesten
dazu ist es meist klar es bildet sich
wieder Nebel es gibt nur wenige
Wolkenfelder und wenn sich der Nebel
morgen aufgelöst hat strahlt wieder
verbreitet die Sonne am Nachmittag
allerdings kann es aus den Alpen heraus
einige Regenschauer und Gewitter geben
im Allgäu oder auch am Bodensee die
höchst Temperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 21 Grad an der See und 28 Grad
am Oberrhein dann kommt ein sehr
spätsommerliches Wochenende bei 21 bis
30 Grad und am Montag Beenden von Westen
dann Unwetter diese Spätsommer Episode
guten Abend